bien mesdames messieurs le bureau
politique s'est réuni ce soir mardi 29
novembre 17h45
l'ordre du jour était d'examiner une
résolution unique et cette résolution
est prévue par les articles des statuts
des républicains en l'occurrence
l'article 39 alinéa 4 des statuts qui
indique que lorsque le candidat à la
présidence de la république
désigné à l'issue de la primaire est
issu du mouvement les républicains il
propose au bureau politique les
conditions dans lesquelles la direction
du mouvement est assurée donc
conformément à l'application des statuts
des républicains françois fillon a
proposé au bureau politique
l'organisation suivante
tout d'abord le bureau politique est
présidé par le candidat à la présidence
de la république issu du mouvement
ensuite il est créé un comité politique
qui assure la plénitude des pouvoirs et
des attributions du bureau politique
dans l'intervalle des réunions de ce
dernier ce comité politique est composé
de la façon suivante monsieur gérard
larcher président du sénat monsieur
christian jacob président du groupe
l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale et bruno retailleau président
du groupe l'est républicain au sénat
madame virginie calmels ce première
adjointe au maire de bordeaux et vice
présidente de bordeaux métropole
monsieur françois baroin sénateur de
l'aube
madame nathalie kosciusko morizet député
de l'essonne
monsieur thierry solère député des
hauts-de-seine
monsieur jean frédéric poisson député
des yvelines et monsieur jean françois
copé député de seine-et-marne
comme il ne vous a pas échappé ce sont
là les représentants où les candidats
qui étaient concurrents de françois
fillon dans le cadre de la primaire et
qui se retrouvent tous présents ou
représentés au sein de ce comité
politique sont en outre membre de droit
du comité politique les deux vice
présidents le secrétaire général et les
deux secrétaires généraux adjoints
françois fillon a en effet voulu revenir
à la situation antérieure existantes
avant la démission de nicolas sarkozy
pour pouvoir devenir candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre sur
le fonctionnement du comité politique
le comité politique est convoqué et
présidée par le président du sénat il
délibère dans les mêmes conditions que
le bureau politique il est créé deux
vice-présidents monsieur laurent
wauquiez ancien ministre et député de
haute l'eau en or madame isabelle le
callennec député d'ille et vilaine il
est créé un secrétariat général qui est
composé d'un secrétaire général monsieur
bernard acoyer ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale et député de haute
savoie de deux secrétaires généraux
adjoints
monsieur gérald darmanin ancien député
et premier vice président de la région
ou de france et madame annie genevard
député du doubs le secrétaire général a
la responsabilité d'assurer l'exécution
des décisions du bureau politique et du
comité politique et représente le
mouvement dans tous les actes de la vie
civile
la présidence de la commission nationale
d'investiture est assurée par monsieur
jean françois lamour député de paris
il sera assisté de deux vice-présidents
monsieur
roger karoutchi ancien ministre et
sénateur des hauts-de-seine et monsieur
alain marleix qs ancien ministre et
député du cantal cette résolution unique
a été adopté à l'unanimité du bureau
politique
la première réunion du bureau politique
aura lieu mardi dans exactement quinze
jours je vous remercie et je suis bien
sûr à votre disposition pour répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions